today on Katy can you swim with the
sharks
the cast of shark tank on how to launch
your million-dollar idea they almost
need to have you a hello right what
these sharks did before making it big
time mark you taught disco yes I did a
sharks as seen on TV show down and our
Mothers of Invention aim to win a huge
prize sharks what do you think
nice to see you all of course that was I
kind of pop singing all night it begins
with the words we all dream about the
better life and who doesn't right we'd
all like to come up with that big idea
that will make us Millions it'd be the
key to that better life but sometimes to
get there yep you gotta swim with the
sharks Denton Denton Denton of course
I'm talking about the cast of shark tank
the hit ABC show millions of us watch
every Friday night we're gonna have a
lot of fun with them today so here's a
look at the only show I know we're
getting a big shark to bite is a good
thing just when you thought it was safe
to go back in the water
he's greedier than you are or at least
to weight in the world of big business
oh I have never seen such great ABC's
hit series shark tank introduces
would-be entrepreneurs to some of the
most successful business owners in
America I have a really cool product
that makes the lives easier and safer
for moms and children everywhere the
goal get a shark to back your big idea
you're gonna get slaughtered
real estate mogul Barbara Corcoran took
a $1,000 loan and turned it into a five
billion dollar business I didn't like
you them and I don't like you now
billionaire Mark Cuban heads up a media
empire and owns the Dallas Mavericks you
have to say yes right now we're not
asking for money for a handout you want
to sell something or do you not
technology Titan Robert Herjavec family
came to this country with just $20 do
you have money on the table why would
you be here and he sold his first tech
company for 100 million like the product
I just don't trust you meanwhile the
queen of QVC Lori Grenier has created
over 400 products and holds a hundred
and fifteen patents I can tell instantly
if it's a hero or a zero and I'm sorry I
think this is a zero Brandie mogul
Daymond John sold tight top hats on the
streets of Queens New York and took a
one day sale of eight hundred dollars
and turned it into 350 million you
didn't come to make a deal I didn't
waste your time don't waste ours and
kevin O'Leary launched his software
company out of his basement and went on
to sell it for 3.7 billion dollars
why would I ever give you money fifty
four billion dollar industry every guy
comes in here and says that for the
contestants it's sink or swim from the
moment they
as they tried their best to catch a big
fish Mark Cuban's Barbara Corcoran
Daymond John Kevin O'Leary and Robert
Herjavec
this is so fun so fun to have you all
thank you for coming you know I know
Lori hurt her foot so she couldn't be
here today but we're really happy all of
you are and I'm just curious mark the
show is hugely popular I love watching
it I think you all do a fantastic job by
the way even though you make me mad
sometimes we leave but I guess that's
part of the job why do you think the
show is such a big success because the
American Dream is alive and well and I
think you know in the past a parent
would tell their son or daughter to set
up a lemonade stand and realize they
could be successful now you can watch
Shark Tank and see that anybody with a
great idea that really puts in a lot of
hard work you know a dream can come true
and obviously if we can get to this
point of being sharks anybody can be
successful and you know you guys are
really putting literally your money
where your mouths are because you are
taking your money and personally
investing in some of these products why
did you want to do that Barbara because
in the beginning I thought I would make
money on every single entrepreneur until
I found out that I only make money on a
third of them really yes yeah Mike when
you're third 1/3 and 2/3 you lose your
money all the crap well have you guys I
mean have a better track record than
Barbara then they're gonna lie like
crazy I agree it's the thing about Shark
Tank you think about the exposure
products goods and services get on it
and we're the investor it's like the
American Idol of venture capital nobody
gets the exposure that a shark tank
product gets so you take a product like
wicked cupcakes in Boston they went from
16 thousand a week in sales to 380,000
after Shark Tank
which acts the shark tank effect and it
must make you feel so good does a demon
to be able to give a platform to these
entrepreneurs who who come in with a
wish or a dream or even a product and
you're able to to either make their
dream come true or take their product to
the next level it's amazing I you know I
grew up boating the number one under
achiever of my high school
didn't have any way to take it to like
that you go back to your high school and
say Nandini well you know what I hired
half my high school but we the center
but to be able to hand that down and see
the sparkle in those entrepreneurs eyes
that we had or we still have and be able
to be part of their dream them allowing
us to be part of the dream it's just
it's an amazing field but Robert you
also have to be that their reality check
you know and you have to be honest and
and break some hearts is absolutely how
do you know when a product really is you
know it's just got that it factor okay
they think we're all different I think
for me it's always about the
intrapreneur less so the product I mean
Barbara will invest in anything that is
okay so but you know we like to have a
lot of fun but you look for the person
that can make stuff happen you want a
good operator now you you are all very
successful clearly as we just saw in
that tape but but you you started out
with some very interesting jobs doing my
homework for this interview Barbara I
read you had 22 different jobs including
selling hot dogs really is one of the
better ones
all right now meanwhile I know that mark
you taught disco serious ideas I mean I
take good money to have you teach me the
hustle go alright so come on so
I don't mind watching you dance but did
you have to make us watch heads pretty
good no good right you bet you I have to
say you know I tend to try to lead and
you wouldn't let I would like that so
what did you learn the course that I'm
out of breath what did you learn from
teaching disco yeah anytime someone
offers you $25 an hour to go to a
sorority house and teach just that makes
sense and then I know that Robert and
Daymond you both were waiters Daymond
you were actually a waiter at Red
Lobster is that right oh you know those
cheese biscuits when they came out with
those biscuits there after I went to the
kitchen to the mm time for one table for
those cheese biscuits I said there's got
to be a better way well I'm so happy to
have you all here we're gonna have a lot
of fun today and the question I'm asking
our audience do you think you have a
million dollar idea we'll stick around
because next the Sharks are offering up
their secrets to success that's right
after this
last time you held a check for $500,000
I have never held me check for [ __ ] what
would that do to your life you know what
I believe in you so much more have you
made how many brands have you rose
that's enough I want to make an offer
I'll do 125 thousand dollars I take your
90,000 and add 0 to it so now we're at
$900,000 I offered a million dollars I
feel great about the future I feel like
everything that I've worked hard for
it's gonna happen now
welcome back those were just a few
memorable moments from ABC's hit show
shark tank these sharks are not afraid
to show their teeth from time to time to
land a big deal Mark Cuban Barbara
Corcoran Daymond John Kevin O'Leary and
Robert Herjavec they were so happy
you're here welcome so good to see you
all live yes Damon first of all what
makes a good pitch I think a good pitch
is some way that can that can basically
tell their idea within a couple of
seconds they can they can show me the
need for it they can make make their
pitch where I can relate to it's like
wow you know what I think that's needed
and then always at the end of a good
pitch is something where they have proof
of concept some form of sales or the
fact that somebody believed in it what
about you Robert I mean what really
captures your attention you have to keep
mind we're sitting there 10 hours a day
we see a lot of pitches you have a very
short amount of time to get our
attention they almost need to have you a
hello right well you got to get me right
away you know some of these great ideas
obviously have turned into great
businesses and two of them are here
today
save and low Mac and Jim sallykaus
started cousins Maine lobster and Mike
Hardwick and Sarah Pond founded surf set
fitness welcome to all of you so nice
I'm your success now I know that Jim and
saving you guys had just launched
cousins Maine lobster her food truck
when you we applied to be on Shark Tank
why did you want to be on the show we
just thought you know what better for
him what better a stage than to get in
front of so many millions of people and
we knew we had a lot to learn we felt
like we had a great concept in a great
business but we knew we had a lot to
learn and I know Barbara invested in
your company Barbara what it was that
they caught your eye you know it was
great about these guys they were in
business three months and none of us
asked the question at the time they're
on Shark Tank because they knew every
answer because they had memorized every
season of shark tank and written three
answers to every shark question for four
years how many people put that kind of
prep into a show Wow they did so you had
a buy-in they were smooth Murray
well Jim and save and we're very happy
for your success and continued success
and thank you for coming by meanwhile
Mike and Sarah you guys invented a surf
based workout machine and routine that
mark invested in all right but I
understand at first you weren't sure you
wanted to be on the show we we honestly
thought they might laugh at us we had no
idea um you know we prepped and study
and I was like what if they go out there
and they see a surf board on land and
they say this is super thing I've ever
seen
but they didn't thank God um and and
it's really been even just working we
said maybe we should start with some
less successful investors you know maybe
we shouldn't go right to the top but
mark has been unbelievable for us yeah
and so why did you think this product
was a winner and these these two were
winners well first I looked at the
product and as someone who works out all
the time I knew immediately this was a
far better way to do core workouts as
opposed to the balls and everything that
just are impossible and you know they
obviously have charisma they were
committed to the product and they also
had a track record you know so they knew
what they were doing they could execute
on their plan and it was just a question
of them scaling and getting big ad this
one still pisses me off yeah
love the hearing I I'm the only athletic
shark up here I want to play with this
so badly
and you know sometimes it happens well
you know what I want to play with it
badly too and since this show is called
Katie and that Shark Tank I get to
Robert know how this works
oh gosh and I hope I hope you have
insurance
oh yeah so basically how does this work
out work I just you just want me to get
on when on the run yeah okay I don't
know how to surf so don't have to go and
show your dance nice and wide and you
see the board's shifting constantly so
you're gonna have to engage your core I
need a little Hawaii v there you go
perfect I think it's kind of good for
your bump as well otherwise Oh probably
just DB then absolutely one more let's
have a boarding stuff and a lot of
Pilates your hard stuff yeah oh so okay
go ahead move on you're moving all over
the bar come over here so I can all
right I use your toes be careful I've
engaged
okay you see we're using a closed grip
the board yeah your core yeah so a lot
of the moves are all core intensive so
yeah when we're doing squats push-ups
you're still gonna be using your core
the entire work now how did you guys
think of this idea I'm just curious I
moved back from California for a job in
Boston and literally couldn't get to
waves I was trying to surf and couldn't
be in enough shape to go on a surf trip
came into an equinox and actually saw
Sarah I had this prototype about
surfboard on a BOSU ball sure enough she
came over and she said what are you
doing I was like well I'm trying to get
the workout that I do surfing and she
said no no let me let me help you that's
really where we hit it off and started
the company and did you hit it off in
more ways than one
Oh yep all right
you guys alright you can go to Katie
Couric comm I'm gonna hold on to you
mark for special offers from both surf
set Fitness and cousins Maine lobsters
I'm going to hang ten the Sharks are
going to hang around we're gonna play a
little game right after this